welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and one division's mysteries are
starting to come into focus now that
episode 4 took us outside of west view
and gave us terrifying context from
avengers end game and avengers infinity
war
and now promo footage for episode 5
dropped in some
huge clues for the epic showdown ahead
is disney ruining everything with these
promos
i don't think so only really the curious
cats probing into the visual details
with re-watch upon rewatch risk nearing
that precious truth and even then we
usually end up with
more questions on our jimmy woo new
rockstars trolling boards
so let us break down everything we
learned about wandavision from this
episode 5 sneak peek
let's get started
we now have first person intel from
inside the west view anomaly okay these
are mostly visuals from the most recent
episode here
except now hayward is jumping on this
opportunity to have monica back so that
he can get some details from inside
westview
based on my theories about this guy i'm
sure he's real eager to be the first one
to interview monica now this sword
command center has this awesome
map table with the globe of the sword
logo rotating i like how the outer layer
this logo has
eight stars four on each side of a
central bright ninth star
i wonder if these could represent the
nine realms with midgard aka earth in
the center on that sword across the
continents are some blinking texts
one in the east mediterranean off the
southern coast of turkey another that
for a second looks like it's around my
hometown of jacksonville florida
duval
though if sword headquarters is based on
cape canaveral this could be
showing sword hq blue on the screens
behind them show what looks like the 80s
episode
inside west view the family ties looking
home set
agnes dressed up as uh kitty gibler from
full house i'm actually assuming we will
get some kind of meta nod to olson's
sister's work on that show
next clip what are we looking at here is
it an alternate reality
time travel it's a sitcom starring two
avengers
a working theory again more stuff from
past episodes except
this new shot that looks like it is from
the 80s episode intro
jean skirt visions calculator watch many
have noticed how consistently
everyone in westview appears to wear
watches despite the time dilation
jimmy wu does ask if time travel is
going on and he wrote same time and
space
on the board and with the strucker watch
the clock radio the clock and toaster
commercial
time is important in fact out of sync
clocks
could be key to vision's awakening and
based on the norm notes in episode 4 how
he is awakening
others in the town and then the way the
camera pushes in on them kissing in the
park reminds me of the motion of that
shot in the full house opening remember
how it
rushes up on the tanners in that park in
san francisco probably fleeing aunt
becky hitting them up for bail money ooh
next clip life moves fast out in the
suburbs i think something's wrong here
should we just take it from the top why
that
i don't know how any of this started
what is outside of westfield
okay wanda is in her sitcom kitchen
cleaning up a bunch of toys
now we know the 80 set will feature the
boys still as babies and we see wanda in
this outfit later on that 80s set so
this is all still the 80s these boys
would be older now
maybe aging too fast for the decades to
keep up now it's interesting that agnes
breaks character in resets this way
should we just take it from the top
normally wanda is the one to break
reality halt everything edit these
scenes in progress
from within so the fact that agnes is
making the call here
might suggest that wanda's ability to
edit these moments does not work on
agnes kind of like that stork
agnes is another unaccounted for west
view component that is beyond
wanda's control more footage we've seen
before of wanda's modern family or
malcolm the middle home
it's glitching through layers of
construction but then vision says this
what is outside of westfield this sounds
pretty emotional here like truman for
the truman show demanding to leave
seahaven what's on the outside
and then we see vision trying to push
out through that cmbr static wall
i'm thinking this could be right after
that nighttime footage of him
soaring up over westview from the
trailer for the first time getting a
sense of this fictitious reality and
realizing
i gotta get out of this next clip
yeah i'm not sure what that's about it's
probably just a case of the mondays
am i right here once again the closing
shot of episode four when i pointed out
how shiftyvision's eyes
are looking out over that tv set
directly at us
but then this armored sword vehicle
carrying
some kind of cargo rams the westview
border wall
as it is lit up red now we have seen it
glow this threatening color in other
shots
i feel like this is what westview looks
like when wanda feels threatened
based on the windows of that vehicle
this looks like the vehicle that the
pilot is in not the helicopter
in that other cockpit interior shot that
we've seen now this vehicle is numbered
92-19r
i did check to see if there's any
significant 1992 vision scarlet witch
comic or just maybe not every number on
the show means something but then a much
clearer version of another shot that
we've seen before the static wall as
some
silhouette comes through it you can
actually see their leg as it's coming
through
right before it cuts off now i actually
don't think this is vision as we saw on
the other shot of him leaving west view
based on the
coat and the hair it actually looks more
like wanda maybe she's coming out to
confront sword but look low into the
left of this figure
it looks like they are carrying
something maybe dragging something
behind them
is this wanda with one of swords drones
that she's tossing back out or
is this that truck after she turned it
into a toy
a toy that maybe one of her kids starts
playing with yikes but before i continue
thank you to adam and eve for sponsoring
this video
valentine's day is right around the
corner and if your adult relationship
would like some more adult fun added to
it
our friends over at adamandeve.com are
here to help they have
a huge selection of sexy gifts to give
your partner including a lot of products
that i can't say out loud on a youtube
video
but are very thought provoking when you
look at them on a website
adam and eve has been in the business
over 49 years helping couples and other
folks interested in improving their
groovin
they got a great 24 7 customer service
and a 90 day no hassle return policy
adam and eve also uses 20
of their profit to fight the spread of
hiv around the world
so you can feel extra good about
spending some money to you know feel
extra good use our code rockstar at
adamindy.com to get
50 off one item and free shipping in the
us
and canada some exclusions apply again
that's code rockstar
to save 50 on one item at adamandeve.com
then wanda's lined directly to camera is
total claire dunphy for modern family
and also giving us a bit of irony
inspired by office space i gotta get out
of here i think i'm gonna lose it
uh oh sounds like somebody's got a case
of the mundus
but really the biggest new stuff of this
trailer comes in the very final seconds
whoa so wanda uses her red chaos magic
to levitate in some
interesting looking facility it looks
like rows and rows of
office drawers but at impractical to
reach heights it almost looks like
soundproofing panels
and then a glass paneled walkway with
what looks like office blinds behind her
so where is this it does kind of seem
like a
sword facility but nothing in their camp
outside westview would be this elaborate
i'm thinking this could be
wanda's mind palace a mental database
or library there have been a ton of
sightings of the westview library it
could be a manifestation of
wanda's memories things that if you
think about it she definitely has
compartmentalized emotionally at least
or we could be seeing a flashback to
wanda's time at sokovia when she was
working with hydra something we know
will be important on this show
maybe these panels are part of a kind of
danger room
training grid then vision and wanda are
part of some kind of super superpower
conflict
in the west view neighborhood and the
distance behind vision appears to be a
car on fire
i am now wondering if this whole
westview anomaly is the aftermath
of some other avengers level crisis that
wanda initially went to try to help
but in order to contain it she had to
create this kind of hex
to resurrect vision which ended up with
all of them trapped inside it that
initial crisis could have been caused by
jimmy woo's missing witness as a way to
lure wanda in
and then this red tinted shockwave turns
a 50s black and white city block into a
modern technicolor one i actually think
this particular shot could be in reverse
a blue car on a normal street being
warped into the 50s sitcom reality wanda
envisioned
started this series in then a crazy shot
of vision
outside the static wall look very
closely at this his cape is still
dragging him back in
no capes but look closely at vishen's
forehead looks like there's a bit of a
divot
where that mine stone was yanked out so
yeah vision on the outside of westview
could be reverting to creepy corpse form
as he would because he's dead he could
be
falling apart second by second with
chunks of him being dragged back in the
west view
and he looks like he is screaming maybe
for help from those sword agents like
maybe wanda is
keeping him from leaving a sort of
reversal of the way he tried to keep her
in the avengers compound in civil war i
mean if vision is aware that he is dead
he might prefer
death over this creepy false afterlife
and then in the final shot vision and
wanted levitate to face each other in a
kind of tense looking standoff her float
off
trouble in paradise i do think
wandavision is gonna become
wanda vs vision but check it out a
little dog house with the name
sparky sparky is the name of vision
synthesis dog from the tom king vision
series
one of the many comic series inspiring
this show actually i think this series
seems to be pulling from pretty much
every major scarlet witch and vision
comic title it's hard to say
whether any one of them is a bigger
influence on the story than any other
one of them
oh by the way i am wearing our latest
obsession shirts an unusual couple
limited supplies still available at our
merch store newrockstarsmerch.com
and we are now answering your questions
live three times a week monday wednesday
friday on
stereo you can download stereo for free
at stereo dot com
new rockstars you can follow me on
instagram at eavos follow me rockstars
subscribe to rockstars on youtube for
breakdowns of all your one division what
the [ __ ]
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you